hi Oslo
hello world
let's code an incremental Source
generator with Roslin
today the next 60 hours
60. why 60 hour minutes we will learn or
about about what source generators are
where they are in use they definitely
came to stay they will not go away and
how we can build one ourselves
my name is Stefan poltz I'm from Austria
ilove.net and c-sharp I started with
rostlin actually when the when the
pandemic started
then with Source generators I started
when they got actually released together
with.net 5.
and currently I'm a senior software
developer to report in Vienna
I also have a
um
twitch and YouTube stream currently also
streaming about wrestling that's my
that's my hammer and every problem that
I have is a nail
um I am a co-organizer of the.net Meetup
in Vienna a Microsoft MVP and a chat
brains Community contributor which the
where the letter may come in handy to
you if you take a picture of this stage
or in the overflows room of the of the
screen and either tweet it and tagged me
with at 0x underscore F0 or send it via
Twitter Mastodon or LinkedIn as a
private message then I will raffle two
white chat points wider licenses at the
end of the day
so what is wrestling waslam is the open
source compiler platform for net and it
supports both the c-sharp and the visual
basic programming languages
who view has used wrestling or something
with whistling maybe an analyzer or
codefix provider consciously already
see a third of the room with you has
used a source generator in particular
already
okay like
10 hands roughly and who has built
already a social innovator
there's one two three okay four uh I
hope that we have quite a quite a um
spread in the experience level with
firstly and Fortune readers I hope that
I have a takeaway for for all of you and
after the session please let me know if
I if I if I delivered um by by voting
for for the session
so in Roslyn this is a compiler as a
platform we can write our own plugins
such as an analyzer which produces
sprinklers warnings and errors and also
a code fixed provider where we then can
either enter or control dot this
Diagnostic and we get fixes um so
suggested such as using newer language
features um why does this a lot
and with whistling 3.8 which got shipped
in the 2005 SDK we also got Source
generators and we've got net six
incremental Source generators well the
difference is we will find out in the
next minutes
so
social media's got released with.net 5
and with net 6 and.net 7 Microsoft is
also building Source generators and
supplying them in the in as part of the
of that of the of the.net framework so
when we Target open six or dot Net 7 we
get the source generators out of the box
for example system takes Json Source
generator one for logging this is if you
have seen the talk from Nick chopsters
yesterday about logging he showed this
as well
and in.net 7 there is actually three
more I missed one a wedge hex generator
an interop generator and also a
JavaScript interoper generator and
dotnet8 will have more more generators
coming
um
because
oh yeah now let's go there
um because they have very specific the
use cases
um
let's go let's go to examples first
so how could a social meter look like
let's actually take a look at the
logging Source generator
so I'm having here a benchmark
I'm using the sorry I forgot to
launch the tool
I feel the standard extension methods
logging that we have logger.information
we put in a message and sends the
parameters
but this has a bit of a problem because
this params area sorry
this params array here is actually
an object away
and not only do we allocate
in a way here implicitly by the c-sharp
compiler but also if we have value types
such as this number here this is an
integer we box them to a reference type
to the object which means we have
additional Heap allocations which causes
pressure on the garbage collector
and with a source generator can produce
very specific source code for our for
our need here to avoid these
allocations
and how this works is we create
ourselves a new type we make it partial
so that the source generator can add new
sources to it
and we Define now our partial method in
previous rules
before c sharp 9 we couldn't have an
accessibility modifier on partial
methods we needed to write partial
methods like this when we add the
partial modifier now the new c-sharp
nine rules applied and they mean we need
to have an implementation if there is no
implementation this won't compile with
previous without the without the
accessibility modifier
extension methods had to be void they
couldn't return anything
that means if there is no implementation
then the call to this method actually
will be stripped out of the compilation
but when we do apply the new rules there
has to be an implementation but a lot of
limitations have been have been relaxed
and we do need an implementations but
where is this coming from I didn't write
this so if I go to the implementation
via F12 here we see we are now in a
generated file they usually get marked
with the file name it's not a file name
this file doesn't really exist it's a
it's a hint for tooling it's a suffixed
with dot g dot CS it would also be dot
generated.cs which is a marker for
tooling for example for wider or Visual
Studio or posting analyzes that this is
a generated file and the user has no
direct influence of how this is
generated or how this file is written we
also have the auto generated content
comment on top of the file which is a
further indicator this is generated
and now this creates a this has this
logger message.define has been available
previously already but it's rather
tedious to to to set up this novel The
Source generator takes from us and it
depends automatically and now has
strongly typed overloads so we don't
have this
away allocation anymore from the parents
array and we have no boxing and this
shows in benchmarking
so if we compare actually in The
Benchmark I also log
um with a minimum you know with a
minimal um version with a minimal logger
log level so if we actually if the logo
is
okay sorry
um because we log here in an information
but if we set the minimum level
to warning then this information isn't
locked and in this example when I set to
warning then we actually don't log
anything but still in the in the
standard extension method approach we
still have this allocation
and now with the source automated
version we use the source generated
version we don't have this allocation
anymore and it's also significantly
faster because we avoided those
allocations
another use case is to avoid tedious
implementations
for example in ink summer based
applications
I have here a very basic
application
where I want to bind
a number and want to have two commands
an increment and a decrement command
and which when you have a look at the
code behind right at the viewmodel
implementation we actually don't
implement this I notify property changed
anywhere and we don't Define our
commands and such which is always the
same pattern it always looks the same
but we still have to do it because this
is how the plumbing Works under the hood
but we are the mbvm toolkit Source
generators that are available as a
nougat package from the mbbm tool from
the community toolkit
this is this cannot be all generated
so let's run the application briefly
now we have the increment and document
function functionality without us
actually writing this I probably did not
ever changed and the commands and the
source is actually producing this now
the experience is very similar in in
Visual Studio we can go to our
dependencies
then find the source generators here and
here we can see okay
now the The Source meters from the mbvm
toolkit are kicking in and we can see
the documents that they create they're
not necessarily Files The Source
generator files are not necessarily put
to disk there is a compiler flag that
you can set if you want to have them put
potentially checked in in a source as
well to get a diff but by default they
are not really on disk so it's not files
it's documents and again here we are
now rear marked via.g.cs and the auto
generated comment
and he is not the implementation the the
property did notify changed
implementation so all the code that we
didn't have to write ourselves
and the third use case is that all of
this facilitates
trimming and Native aot
so with the last example
is the Json serializer that got shipped
with Net 7 and improved in.net uh six
and improved in.net 7.
now what I'm having here is a again a
partial class that derives from the Json
serializer context and as an attribute I
Define which type that this
serializer context should be able to
serialize and deserialize I can also set
options for example I want to have it
indented
and again if we go to the implementation
I didn't write anything I only have the
partial file but with this attributes on
a software that creates a lot of code
and very specific
um civilization and deserialization and
strongly typed and there is no
reflection
because the default implementation if we
just if we use civilize and deserialize
without the source traded version what
system text Json does under the hood
because there is a reflection involved
and reflection is expensive so what they
do is when the very first time you
serialize and what this serialize into a
deserialize an object of a specific type
the system takes Json civilizer is
emitting
via reflection.mit new IL code that is
that compiled once and then reused so
it's creating a special case
implementation at one time which is the
problem it's at one time and in Native
aot scenarios where we don't have the
jit compiler we can't we can't do
reflection emit
and now if we do this if we shift this
creation of this object from from one
time to compile time now this is aot
friendly because there is no there is no
need for the chit because the
um the Western compiler is already
taking care of that
and it's also very nice for trimming
because we don't have any unreferenced
code no Dynamic code emitted so the
compiler knows exactly what code is
invoked and our application keeps
trimming friendly
um I'm okay I haven't explained what
trimming is this is what A New Concept
if you have a self-deployed application
usually they are rather big because you
have the entire
um the.net runtime all of the vcl
included and with trimming the link goes
in and sees Rich methods and with which
types and methods are not used are not
referenced by any code and removes them
so that the final binary is is coming is
becoming smaller and so we can have
smaller smaller self-contained
applications and Native alt is a new
approach where we don't have the jit
compiler so everything is compiled for a
specific platform for example in my case
it will be windows 64. and directly
to machine code so there is no chit
anymore so the startup performance of
the applications is very fast and this
is very suitable for for serverless
applications like Azure functions or AWS
Lambda because we save a lot of this
cold startup time
and this is another use case with Source
generators come in handy and there will
be more and more of them
so what are the laws of source
generation
we retrieve
the input to a source generator is the
compilation the compilation is basically
all of the source code and its
dependencies of the project
and this is represented with syntax
trees and the semantic model
what does a syntax tree look like if we
go to sharplab.io
we can we can enter some code and then
well the default is is the c-sharp
version so it actually compiles and
decompiles the code so it basically gets
rids of all the syntactic sugar
and we can also change it to the syntax
tree which is not a waslam
representation of our source code it's
now a tree which has nodes and tokens
and trivia where a node has children
tokens are terminal they are Leaf nodes
and trivia is something that has no
influence on the compilation something
that is not part of the iil code such as
comments
we don't find comments in the IL code
so at the top we have a compilation unit
which is basically this entire document
then we have a using directive
now this using directive consists of a
using keyword it has an identifier name
if it drill down to this identifier name
which is an which is a node now this is
a token system
then we have a class declaration we
could also have a struct declaration
well an interface declaration and again
we list we see all all the keywords that
we have in use here public class are
represented here in the in the
tokenified version of our source code as
well and there is a method declaration
this method declaration it has a return
type now this return type is a
predefined type predefined types of
language types such as void int double
again an identifier identifiers are
always these that basically we can then
invoke in our source code
and also where is our trivia
I think
put a comment on top
to also see here is a comment that is a
single line comment trivia you can also
have multi-line comment trivia or
pre-processor directives
the pound if is also trivia
and this tree is not an input to the
source generator and we can analyze this
tree detect patterns for example this
attribute now this the Json generator
would search
for all partial classes that that are
attributed with this with this attribute
then drills down into the type that is
used in here and then inspects then
basically goes to the type understands
that this type has two properties it's
doing at an in property and generates
the special case civilization code at
compile time for us
and this is the syntax tree what is the
semantic model the semantic model now
gives meaning to our source code
my favorite example here is what if we
could have we could return let's say an
INT 32 here
let's return one
but what if I in the same compilation
now Define my own type let's also make
it obstruct
int32
now
we already get a this doesn't compile
anymore because now it's actually our
int32 and not the system in 32. if I
wanna
um
avoid this this confusion I could go to
the global to the global namespace Elias
and now here have again the the net
um
system of course
and now the compiler one disappears and
this is where the semantic information
comes in
from a
from a syntax view those are both into
32 that could live also if I would put
this in a system namespace then from a
from a syntactic point I couldn't really
differentiate them but for we had a
semantic model now the semantic model
actually gives meaning to these types
and I know now we had a semantic model
okay this is the this is the the BCL
int32 that is equivalent to the int
keyword and this is some other struct
which is empty it has no members so they
don't match
and with this input The Source generator
can then analyze it and produce new code
it's really it's a string that is
produced we can produce zero or an
infinite amount of new strings each of
those strings is then a new document
that we should suffix with.g.cs so the
tooling knows is a generated file and
this really is a string we will see this
later with the live example
Source generators are additive only they
can only add no Source this is no what's
the aspect oriented programming model
where we can actually replace or delete
code during doing compilation this is
currently not possible there is
potentially something in a smaller scope
coming up with.net 8 in preview
something like interceptors where we can
have a bit of an influence at the flow
but it will never be will will
replacement
social generators are analyzers
technically so they can also produce
Diagnostics
we shouldn't we should actually use
um
uh proper analyzer diagnostic analyzer
but I come to the Y at the end but
technically it's very possible
and the source generator can also look
at additional files in our compilation
I have for example here
example where we have some additional
text and if we mark this additional text
as additional file in our compilation
not a source generator could see this as
well and with that we could basically
build a transpiler from Json to c-sharp
if we if we wish
or we could also put some configuration
in these files that we then recognize
social generators are
unordered so we don't know in which
order they want if we have seven Source
generators or in our project all of
these seven Source units get the same
input they cannot depend on each other
that means they are oblivious
and I already mentioned the technical
analyzers
right from the
from the language perspective
in C sharp 2 we got we got the partial
we got the partial types and in C sharp
three we then got partial methods
although I mentioned this they could
only void
but with C sharp 9 is basically support
for Source generators we can now have
more powerful partial methods and I
think all of the all of the Microsoft
Source generators are actually based on
some partial model so I create a file
and create a method that I attribute it
with an attribute and then this partial
method will be implemented by the
generator
and in C sharp 11
we have also file scoped types this
helps also with generators because if
the generator creates a a type that I
already created manually as well that
have the same name in the same namespace
and this is a ambiguity so in order to
avoid that I could make some of my types
which clash with the generator as file
type and then although they have the
same name they won't clash anymore
okay now let's get into building a
source generator
the example that I would like to show is
enum is defined
so we have actually let's go to the
benchmarks
what we have here is basically a version
the PCL version of is defined in.net
framework this wasn't generic yet but
um in.net co-ops.net7 that I'm using
here it's also there's a
there's a generic overload of it
and the is defined has a bit of a
performance implication because under
the hood it does reflection again to
inspect this enum and then give us the
information whether the type the the
constant that we give in is actually
defined and I think it caches it then in
an in an array and then does a binary
research on that and for smaller sized
genomes this is not the fastest
so an actual faster version would be if
we would handle it ourselves if we just
have for this log level that's the
Microsoft extensions logging log level
type where we have our seven constants
we could basically Define it ourselves
and say if this value give in is any of
these then it is defined otherwise it's
not
but this manual implementation is yeah
it's tedious I know exactly I know ahead
of time exactly what I'm going to be
writing if I would implement this for a
different enum it would look like it
would look exactly the same well it had
the same logic of just iterating through
all the checking all the constants and
if a new value to this log level would
be added I must not forget to actually
add it to my manual implementation as
well this is a bit tedious and also a
bit of a maintenance well hell is a bit
of an overstatement but the maintenance
risk and now this is a super example of
a source generator because I already
know ahead of time what I should
generate and basically it's this as a
string
so the example that I would like to have
is
again we Define a partial a partial type
where the source generator then can add
methods in
and we attribute this with the is enum
defined attribute this is a c-sharp 11
attribute it's actually a generic
attribute
um with the enum type so we constraint
this this must be an enum
and then the search motor can kick in
and generate code for that
now I like testing especially when
starting a generator and then it gets
bigger and bigger it's from my
experience really really helpful to have
to have a suit of tests to not break
previously working scenarios
and there is a package from Microsoft
which is called
into one project right yes there it is
microsoft.codonealysis.csharp.swatch.testing
dot Ms test
so what we see here is because the
source generators are the compiler
platform for both c-sharp and Visual
Basic we could also write the source
unit for Visual Basic
F-sharp we can't because F sharp is not
using wrestling
and there is an MS test implementation
of this testing framework we could also
select X unit there's also packages for
X unit and end unit
and with this package we can now Define
our tests and what we see there is a lot
of strings I'm using wall string
literals here I really really like them
especially for for testing whistling
related code
I have here an input it is this
attribute that we that we saw I also
want to generate this attribute at
compile time
and this is actually a nice feature from
from Rider if we enable syntax
inspections
I believe
then yeah then what actually when does
this C sharp chord because it put here
they think it's called a language
injections actually when does this
string be a s c sharp syntax
but even without this highlighting in in
other Ides
I really like the it was doing literals
because we can really nicely format our
c-sharp code
and I have one test where we if we have
a partial type but there is no attribute
on it the source generator shouldn't
generate anything it should only
generate the attribute which we verify
here this is Edom defined attribute.g.cs
should be should be generated as the
string
then we have another test where we
actually have the attribute on this
partial type
and then we expect actually this method
to be created so we add another partial
class enum info which should have the
name
of
the class where the attribute is on this
is now all this we will get this all
with the cement with the syntactic
information
and then we create an is defined method
and we turn this this condition to see
is it any of this string comparison
constants
now what we do here is we always refer
to the global identifier to the global
namespace Elias
Alias this is because what if the user
defines their own system string
comparison then the source generator
could create code that again has a
violation and then it wouldn't compile
we must be very careful that our source
generator creates code that is
compilable because in the pipeline
now the first step is we get the code of
the user the compilation of the user
then this gets fed in to the source
generator The Source generator now may
add
may or may not add multiple additional
documents and then all of those
documents are compiled again as one and
this is then the final the final result
that will be produced so if I have an
error or I cause an ambiguity in one of
those generated files this entire
compilation will fail
so it's always a good it's always good
good habit to refer to the global to the
global namespace alias
and it's also always good style to add
the auto generated comment on top of the
file so that tooling for example on the
other analyzers understand this is a
generated file I shouldn't really
produce warnings on that file because
the user doesn't really have influence
on this file it's generated by generator
that he or she may not own
and then we expect that this is
enumdefined.g.cs file is generated
and also a bit of a corner case what if
the user defines
multiple
um I don't know what this is a different
example interesting example is where the
user defines a
a class in the
in the global namespace
we need special special attribution for
that because we can't then put it into a
namespace
and again we expect then the according
codes to be generated and also if we
have a enum
In This Very case if it's empty
then we just quit false return false
so now let's get into the anatomy of our
generator
the package that we'll be consuming is
microsoft.codonealysis.csharp.workspaces
I think in this example I'm not I'm
actually not using the workspaces part
we could also there's also a package
which is microsoft.codoness.csharp
which contains the syntactic and
semantic models of onesie sharp and also
the Base Class says for the for the base
interfaces for the source generators
also there is a microsoft.com
assist.analysis package that I always
like to add because it has warnings and
infos about how to use Roslyn correctly
especially when it comes to equality
there were some potential pitfalls there
now I'm doing multi-targeting here this
is not really a supported scenario
Source generators and all other wasting
components analyzers and such they
currently all must Implement net
standard 2.0
this is because of tooling for example
wider the backend of wider is I think
on.net7
but Visual Studio is still on.net
framework so we can't use any.net core
libraries it must be open standard 2.0 I
still do multi-targeting here in order
to get nullable annotations because
the.net standard 2.0
reference assemblies they are not
annotated with nullable annotations yet
but I still like non-ability warnings if
I make some mistakes and this is how I
enable them this is a bit of an advanced
not supported scenarios but in case it
is very helpful to avoid null errors
because generators should not crash
and
then
we start with implementing this
interface here this is already the newer
interface
how many of you do know
the site source.net
I've seen a couple of hands this is the
source code browser for the BCL The Base
Class Library where we for example can
find a value provider
with a not value provider a Time
provider
which is a new abstraction that is
coming up in.net 8. and the same thing
exists also for a waslam source code
which is Source waslin.io by the way all
the resources and things I have there in
the presentation if you want to check
them out later
we can find the interface I Source
generator
and this isosce generator interface is
the one that has been added with.net 5.
and this is actually now considered
deprecated because this has a bit of a
performance
pit fall at some certain sizes I will
come to that later
the newer version that we should use is
the incremental version I incremental
generator
and we will find out what the
incremented what the incrementability
about that is at the end of our example
so we will start implementing this
interface
and we also put the type the attribute
generator on top of this file so that
tooling such as watching tooling the IDE
or the net SDK knows okay this is a
generator this is important as part of
the compilation
and well I said in the beginning that
social meters are unordered and they
cannot depend on each other there is a
little bit of a
um wiggle room there
let's have a look at the versioning
if I
oh right I have that
here
no oops
no
so here all the versions that of waslind
that have been what of wasteland with
Source generator
functionality has been created so it
started with Roslyn 3.8
which is part of the.net 5 SDK and this
added the eyesource generators
now it's 3.9 we got this
concept called register for post
initialization and post initialization
is a step just before the other step so
what we now have is we have our input
the compiler now has the chance of
creating some code unconditionally where
the the generator doesn't doesn't have
the
user's code as an input yet so we can
create some code and unconditionally for
example this attribute I always want to
emit it so this is a good candidate for
that and then in a second step we can
emit
conditional files that are based on on
the users on the user's code and this
step where we create the second set of
documents actually
sees what we create in this post is
initialization
so we have two steps and other
generators so if other generators can
see the code that this channel that is
generated by post initialization from
other generators as well so first all
the post initialization from all the
seven generators we have in our project
are executed and then the channel
execution
and here is now the new version in 4.1
4.0.1 which got shipped with the.net 6.0
SDK we have added I incremental
generators
I also list the tooling visual studio
and Rider which and visual studio code
which support all of all of these
versions
if you want to refer to this later
there it is
so now we have the base of our generator
defined and the compiler doing
compilation can actually use it and call
into it
and in the first step we do this
register for post initialization and in
this post initialization we create
this this attribute I created in the
roslin.generated namespace and it also
has the generated code attribute
attribute so it's always it's also good
to practice that so there's a lot of
best practices of how to generate code
to put the generated code attribute on
top of members and and types that that
you generate so that again tooling knows
that this is a generated file or a
generated this is generated code because
the comment
the auto-generated comment is good for
waslam based tools because waslam has
gets also the that's a comment trivia as
an input but if we build a for example
an MS build extension that is based on
on an il on an already compiled version
of the code this attribute isn't there
anymore and these tools so that these
tools can also understand what generated
code is it's good practice to slap the
generated code attribute on top of these
types and members as well
so now we have this attribute and can
actually use it
if we jump to the example
we can actually use this attribute this
generated attribute
here it is in our example
and now we need to build up our Pipeline
with the incremental generators we built
a pipeline of
first we get an input for example the
source code where also the input could
be additional files like a Json file
that we want to create that we want to
transpile into the sharp code
and then select the interesting parts we
filter the interesting parts for us and
then from that information create a
string that is the new document that we
want to emit
so let's again go to Sharp Lab in order
to know
what we want to search for
in our example we have a partial
class
I call it my class
which has an attribute on it
um
so we also let's omit the attribute it
also has an attribute
and this is what we what we need to
search for
this my class is a so-called class
declaration
so we get all of the notes and tokens
that we see all of the nodes that you
see here get an input get as an input to
the generator so we need to filter all
of the class declarations that also have
the partial keyword because if they
don't have the partial keyword the
search generator can't extend under
equals this type
so let's go find all of these
and we do this via the syntax provider
the name is water revealing it provides
us the syntax information of the user's
source code there is many more providers
there is for example a compilation
provider which contains then semantic
information
we also have the additional text
provider that we saw earlier this could
be the XML or Json file
we also can get a hold of the pass
options this is contains for example
information with which language version
which which is it Visual Basic was a
sharp and which version in our case C
sharp 11 is this called compiled
so we then create a this is actually a
new type this four attribute with
metadata name has been added in
I need to go cheat
has been added in 3.4.3.1
this is the 6
6.0.4 SDK and actually the version from
Wilson that we consume is significant
because that also marks the minimum
required SDK version so that the user
can actually consume The Source
generators so in our case we need at
least the
6.0.4 SDK if I use a higher version for
example version 4.4.0 we would require
at least dot Net 7 SDK so be mindful
about with how many features of
generators you want to use and also
which is the minimum the minimum SDK
requirement for your for your consumers
and with this new version we can
actually it's very simple now to find
syntaxes that actually have an attribute
on top so in our case we get every type
that has
this attribute as a metadata name
in metadata name since we have a generic
attribute I'm sure you've seen this
already in in some debug debug output
when we have a generic method a generic
type it's actually we have at the end a
backtick and then the number of generic
type parameters the type arguments that
this type has so in metadata this is the
name of our of our attribute
and we pass this into our four attribute
with metadata name
and then we can then we have a Lambda a
predicate this predicate returns true
for every node that we are interested in
so we get in all of the syntax nodes so
we get in the
we get in the entire compilation unit
the using directive
and the class declaration and this is
the one that we wanna that we want to
filter
so let's search these let's get a hold
of the node and say is this
a class declaration syntax
and we also want to know
if this class declaration syntax so
let's say
um
syntax
has a partial modifier
these these keywords here they are
called modifiers so we can get a hold of
the
modifiers list
and say do we have any
syntax kind that is
partial
the partial keyword there it is
and this now we turned this now returns
only true for all the class notes that
has that are partial and also have this
attribute
on top well at least one of these
attributes we could also have multiple
it requires at least one
and then we have a transform
so we can now extract the information
that we that we need
so via this context
we get
the information from this from the
predicate that we have before so we do
get the target node the target node is
our class information
so let's extract that because that's a
that's actually the base of syntax
notebook but we can safely cast it
because we have we did our type check up
here already
so this will be our class
declaration
class decoration syntax
and we also want to get the symbol
information behind it
because we require the simple
information
um
in order to get a hold of this type that
we refer to because we then need to
inspect this log level type and
understand all of the of the constants
that are defined at this type
so we will also get a hold of
uh symbol
and
we know in this case I know it's an it's
I named
type symbol it's a symbol that also has
a name and we get this in the context
dot target symbol so there's another
symbolic information the semantic
information
of the class which has this attribute
and we put this and I put this now here
in a in a value Tuple so that the next
step has this as an input
and additionally also the attributes
the attributes list the attribute
data so that we can extract the
information out of that
in the respect of time I have
implemented the rest of the pipeline
already so let's go through the rest of
the pipeline
I'm using immutable array here to create
lists because that fits the worstland
programming model in Roslyn you won't
find any public list list usages because
in Wasteland everything is immutable
that is so that different compilations
can run in parallel they are the entire
syntax tree is immutable and I want to
fit that model and use the immutable
versions of the of the of the
collections as well
so we
what I'm basically doing here is because
we could have multiple multiple
attributes at at a class
I think I have this example I had this
example in our uh in the unit tests so
we extract we extract all of them in a
select many this is very similar to link
but it's actually not link so on the
syntax providers that we have the
pipeline that we built we have
transformations
we can select which is which has the
which has the semantics of the link
select but it isn't actually link it's a
it's a new implementation from the
generators
and we can also collect that means if we
have if we have a collection if we have
multiple multiple matches we can break
this down to a single one so basically
convert it from an
innumerable to an immutable array
and after that
we now need to get all the information
out of those out of those symbols and
those syntaxes because this will come in
handy later
the incremental Source generators due to
the incrementality they allow
memorization of several steps and this
memorization doesn't work well on the
waslam types because they are immutable
and they are in a tree we can't really
say that if in the next if we if we get
in the same compilation again we can't
really say is this now a different class
or not so the quality doesn't really
work on these wrestling types very well
so we need to extract these into
information that is very nicely
equatable for example string information
so what we're doing here we're getting
we're getting the attribute data
and filtering this now I have here an
enum there is enum defined info this is
just a custom record which now holds all
of the information
we get we get the Boolean is this
type that we found is this class in the
global namespace
and also we get the name of the
namespace
we get the name of the Class via the
symbolic information
we also get all of the and now we get
all of the members but we again need to
filter them because while building this
generator actually learns that enorms
also have a
um a Constructor
so we can write
if we have the log level here we could
write
a new log level
every enum also has a has a has a
default Constructor
so we need to filter that one out
oops
and we do that
by we get all of the members of this
type
we want to find and this is now the the
filter we want to find all of the fields
and this now includes the The
Constructor
and then we basically are good to go
and have the final step in the pipeline
the final step is the register Source
output this is then what actually
creates the documents and the strings
so there is various methods how you can
assemble this string I'm using a string
Builder here and wrapping it in an
indented text writer because you can do
nice intention with that and basically
now create line by line the document for
um for the compiler then to compile so
we start with an attribute I also like
to always enable nullable annotations
for these documents
then we go through all of the enum infos
and per Elum info
we create a new namespace if it is in
the global namespace so this is very
relevant because otherwise we would get
compiler errors if if we would try to
access the namespace if it's in a no
Global namespace then I think this is
some unspeakable name which won't
compile
then we create this is the extension
point the partial class
and then we emit the the method that we
want to create
we with the enum type that we have we
have put in the attribute
then we want to understand hey do we
have any constants in this and this in
this enum if not we return false
otherwise again line by line we create
this switch expression
and here we do some indentation to to
format this nicely and then it then we
close all the braces again and at the
very end we then call
the the method add Source this is then
what really really adds this code to the
to the compilation and we give it a
name.g.cs
and now
we actually have
this enum info
generated by our source generator
and again yeah this is now basically the
very same version as the handheld
version but if we would add a new enum
then this would get added automatically
I think I have a to have a test for that
I believe I no I do not but we could add
like another one let's say the the let's
create my let's create our own enum
public you know mine
let's Circle first
let's use this mine here
now we should
also
create
there it is
this is defined here
and when we add another one second
one second
while I type
now the new one gets created we can
actually see this nicely side by side
just as I type
now the solution that kicks in
and soon adds this new uh this new enum
to it it's going to start removing one
the second one will disappear
momentarily
and the cool thing is that in the source
joint version version because it's just
source code that gets emitted by the
compiler we can also add breakpoints
so it's also very debuggable
and now comes the the performance
Pitfall that I mentioned twice already
because the thing is
let's add
in the source code that we generate
so start right line
a
daytime dot now
let's
build oops build our solution
and let's have a look at the example
jump to the generated code
and what we see here now is if I change
the source code without actually
changing anything meaningful for our
generator let's say I add a new line
here currently we're at 11 14 0 3.
and oh sorry I already have to I already
have to fix in place I I gave it away
so let's remove let's remove the fix
there it is
now we have the expected
Behavior by
uh 11 40 or free
11 40 35 and I just add a couple of
spaces and this will
when I save this will but I'll generate
it again but the same version of the
source code is generated again and this
is where we could follow for a
performance Cliff because for example
this is what the net team experienced in
there in the in the dotnet runtime repo
which is huge when the app generators
there is a lot of input code and by just
by just by pressing a space everything
gets created all this generators kick in
and generate everything again which is
an incredible waste of resources and
this is now where the incrementality of
the incremental sourcing just kicks in
but it requires this equality that we
have mentioned and we have one little
issue in our equality pipe in our
equality pipeline
because this type that
defined here
it well it's a record struct so it
actually implements equality but we also
have an immutable array and by default I
think the implement the equals
implementation of a multiplier way
checks reference equality of the backed
away that it has
which is a new instance so this will
never match what we actually need is a
sequence equal so what we could do is
overwrite
equals here in our type because each and
every step in our pipeline that we have
built checks the previous invocation via
a equality compare.default
or we can write our own equality
comparer this is what we did here which
is basically just equaling all of the
members and then on the array there's a
sequence equal
and we can after every step of the
pipeline we could add
dot with comparer and add our own
comparer in which which now means that
in the first step everything gets
created Anew and in a subsequent step is
now if nothing relevant has changed in
this in this enum that we that we create
are in this in this record that we
create as a flow State uh then we abort
the pipeline holds and it doesn't invoke
this um this new source code again so it
doesn't get emitted so if I rebuild that
and go back to the example
here to the email info
and currently write 1170
and now I remove a couple of spaces
and let's wait a couple of seconds this
will not change so in the pipeline now
nothing really meaningful has changed
because we didn't change anything here
but if we change something meaningful
let's say we remove one of the is enum
defines now actually something
meaningful has changed and now it
actually did remove this one not
actually created this this output again
and this is the very important part of
the incremental generator so that
consumers don't experience in the IDE
then a very sluggish a very delayed
experience and potentially even blocks
the UI of of the IDE
so the key takeaway with the key point
with the incremental generators is that
each and every step should rather
quickly or as quickly as possible go
away from the syntax and symbolic
information from Roseland because they
are not nicely equatable and go to some
custom defined nicely equality
comparable structures so that this
pipeline is aborted as early as possible
and we save performance
and
if you in the
best practices I guess we we mentioned
all of them already so always put the
auto generated comments and such on top
refer to the global
namespace alias in order to avoid names
name clashes and so on and definitely
mind the Western version that you use
because that defines the minimum SDK
required
I also have a couple of examples in this
slides and some additional resources if
you want to know more about this
uh if you go to
flashover.net NDC 2023 gen this links to
this very slide uh also with the contact
information uh if there are some
questions I can't answer right now you
can always ask me on any of my socials
if you wish and I try to to answer
Source generated Source generator
particular and voslink general questions
and I guess this now
we have one minute for questions have I
left a question unanswered
okay cool then should I should have fun
just hold on should I have a question
about Chinese later on feel free to to
to contact me and post a picture if you
wanna if you want to take part in the in
the in the in the white Champions raffle
and I want to thank you very much for
staying around and listening
um
[Applause]